- Now, we are getting to
something real good, y'all.
Regina King recently said
that this next guest
seems like Sarah Vaughan
and Ella Fitzgerald are
both living in her body.
That's a beautiful musical
baby. I'm just saying.
She's one of the most
compelling jazz singers
on the scene right now
and you're about to see why and hear why.
Now performing her Christmas
single, "Warm in December,"
give it up for Samara Joy.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
(gentle music)
♪ This heart that glows like an ember ♪
♪ Longs to be loved just by you ♪
♪ If it could be so ♪
♪ Then you'd keep me so ♪
♪ Warm in December too ♪
(upbeat jazz music)
♪ I'll keep you warm in December ♪
♪ Warm when the cold breezes blow ♪
♪ My arms so lovin' ♪
♪ A kind of oven ♪
♪ To melt the sleet and snow ♪
♪ This heart that glows ♪
♪ Like an ember ♪
♪ Longs to be loved just by you ♪
♪ If it could be so ♪
♪ Then you'd keep me so ♪
♪ Warm in December too, ooh, ooh ♪
(upbeat jazz music continues)
♪ This heart that glows like an ember ♪
♪ It longs to be loved just by you ♪
♪ If it could be so ♪
♪ Then you'd keep me so ♪
♪ Warm in December ♪
♪ Warm in December too, ooh, ooh ♪
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- One more time, y'all,
give it up for Samara Joy!
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Gorgeous.
Pick up her single, "Warm in December,"
wherever you get your music.